[Music]
one of america's busiest airports is
back in business
after a serious security breach and a
wild police chase across two runways
authorities want to know exactly how one
car got through a
fence on the perimeter of lax there it
is jonathan vigliotti reports
this was the scene as the driver in a
silver mazda
led police on a high-speed chase across
one of the highest trafficked areas in
the country
the tarmac at los angeles international
airport huge ripple effect here after a
vehicle actually breached the airport
facilities after breaking through a
fence near the airport's fedex cargo
facility
the driver sped past a line of parked
jumbo jets
witnesses then say the car drove across
two busy runways on the airport's south
side
did a u-turn back across them before
coming to a halt
outside a private terminal the large
chain-link gate near the fedex loading
area was found
completely destroyed police gave chase
most of the time until the hatchback
stopped outside atlantic aviation
a charterjet terminal this is a really
crazy one more than a dozen police cars
surrounded the vehicle
and the driver surrendered when the car
came to arrest
the letters inexplicably for now s.o.s
were clearly visible on the hood police
have not released the identity of the
driver or what the motive may have been
nobody was injured during this chase but
the question remains
how a major breach like this could have
happened in the first place
jonathan cbs news los angeles